a qualcuno di voi è senz'altro capitato
di provare a seguire una dieta
se non siete timidi alzate la mano va
bene poi magari una parte di voi non ci
è arrivata in fondo perché a un certo
punto e non ce la fa più
perché il cibo non è poi tanto buono
diciamolo e poi è sempre la stessa
minestra in meno timidi ancora alzino la
mano
ecco la buona notizia che non è colpa
vostra che sono qua per convincervi
queste diete sono perfette dal punto di
vista nutrizionale sono completamente
sbagliate dal punto di vista
gastronomico
cosa significa questo significa che
l'uomo non è banalmente un organismo da
nutrire noi non abbiamo solo uno stomaco
e un intestino che digeriscono
assimilano il cibo quando ci portano
davanti un piatto abbiamo due occhi che
lo contemplano si fanno magari
ingolosire dai colori dalle forme
abbiamo un naso presenti profumi abbiamo
una bocca che sente i sapori percepisce
le consistenze e addirittura due
orecchie che sentono la coppia antezza
quando mastichiamo tutti i cinque sensi
sono coinvolti quando mangiamo quando
mangiamo questi sensi trasmettono
sensazioni era nostra mente generano
emozioni suscitano ricordi
tutto questo avviene in noi mentre
mangiamo e non possiamo farne a meno
perché noi siamo costretti a mangiare
ogni giorno più volte al giorno tutti i
giorni della nostra vita
noi dobbiamo sottoporsi a questa
esperienza e questa esperienza può
essere positiva o negativa può essere
fonte di gioia può essere noi a può
essere anche disgusto è un problema che
dobbiamo risolvere perché ci può portare
anche delle profonde depressioni adesso
non vi chiedo di alzare la mano però a
me capita se mangio male mi sento di
cattivo umore non lavoro nemmeno bene se
invece ho mangiato bene di molto un
teorema è successo
successo bene cosa fa l'uomo da che
mondo è mondo per risolvere questo
problema
s'è inventato la cucina signori perché
l'uomo è l'unico animale che cucina se
noi cuciniamo è perché siamo costretti
ad affrontare questo problema della
sensorialità perché possiamo benissimo
vivere senza televisione senza
elettricità addirittura senza leggero
senza parlare in casi estremi ma se non
mangiamo moriamo è nata la cucina e la
cucina è talmente importante che
addirittura ad oggi in tanti ospedali
stiamo studiando la cosiddetta terapia
del pasto perché mangiare bene dal punto
di vista sensoriale favorisce le due
regioni li accelera ragione esempio
avete presente quei vassoi tipici tristi
dell'ospedale vassoi marroni o bianco
pallido sporco con sopra la mela cotta
la minestrina se vi va bene un
formaggino bianco adesso immaginate un
bel vassoio colorato con sopra dei cv
variopinti profumati con delle forme
fantasiose vi viene voglia di mangiarli
e avete appagamento siete più feriti
guarite prima benissimo
in tutto questo allora io mi aspetto che
la scienza mi dia una forte ma non
risolvere questo problema non è così
semplice in realtà allora la scienza è
molto brava dirci cosa fa bene al nostro
corpo
se però teniamo la stessa prospettiva
cioè di una scienza che ci deve dire
cosa è buono da mangiare abbiamo già
perso in partenza
macché concetto di buono da mangiare non
è un concetto oggettivo non è un
concetto scientifico il buono da
mangiare varia da cultura cultura da
paese a paese da persona a persona e
anche nella vostra giornata dalla
mattina alla sera mi piacevano delle
cose diverse ma dobbiamo cambiare la
prospettiva
cioè noi non vogliamo l'uomo per la
scienza vogliamo la scienza per l'uomo
la scienza che viene incontro all'uomo
allora la scienza deve farsi dire
dall'uomo
cosa gli piace e poi aiutarlo a
realizzare questo cibo che gli piace
come può farlo la propone una sola
innovazione la cucina da quando esiste
ha bisogno costante di innovazione
se prendete il ricettario più antico di
apicio degli antichi romani
vedete che mangiavano mammelle di mucca
ghiri cervella come dolcificante con
divano tutto con una salsa fatta a base
di pesce putrefatto nel rinascimento
spezia vano tutto e il pomodoro e la
patata sono arrivati nella nostra
alimentazione solo alla fine del
settecento quindi la cucina cambia in
continuazione la cucina deve adeguarsi
al cambiamento del mondo della società
il problema è che questi cambiamenti
negli ultimi anni sono diventati
talmente rapidi che la cucina deve
evolversi ancora più rapidamente quindi
innovazione ma perché c'è bisogno di
innovazione sono diversi motivi
allora guardate fatevi una risata con
questo manifesto anni 50 ne esiste anche
una versione italiana ma questa è
stupenda perché internazionale il buco è
buono per te è buono per la tua salute
consigli nutrizionali il governo lo zoe
mangiatene più che potete perché così
lubrificate leve nelle arterie
erano gli anni 50 di anni 50 ok
ecco diciamo che adesso se vedete un
bambino con davanti quei panetti di bovo
che mangia così prendete i genitori
togliete la patria potestà
adesso magari vogliamo ridurre il tono
di grassi saturi dobbiamo cercare di
fare una pasta frolla non col buco ma
magari con un olio molto difficile poi
ve lo dirò quindi cambiano le nostre
conoscenze nutrizionali cambiano in
continuazione le medicina si evolve ma
non è solo questo cambiano anche gli
ingredienti a disposizione vi ho già
citato l'esempio degli antichi romani
posso citare i miei nonni che hanno
vissuto serenamente senza sapere cosa
fosse un kiwi per esempio mentre voi
adesso lo usate per decorare livello
delle vostre torte e poi c'è anche altro
perché cambiano i gusti
perché noi nutriamo non solo il corpo ma
anche la mente
il grande antropologo le liste o si
diceva che un cibo prima ancora che
buono da mangiare a deve essere buono da
pensare cambiano i gusti e questo lo
sappiamo da sempre buona da te questa è
una pagina di un almanacco francese del
1760 siamo prima della rivoluzione e
prima che parlanti entro successo il
consumo della patata facciamo questi
livelli
c'è una filastrocca che rappresenta il
mestiere della cuoca e dice ogni anno
una nouvelle cuisine nuova cucina lo
usavano già allora perché ogni anno
cambiano i gusti e ogni giorno nuovi
rago siate dunque una chimica sui stinca
in nome della cuoca 1760 era già chiaro
e tutto era già chiaro che la scienza
doveva contribuire all'innovazione
allora la scienza che dominava era la
chimica ma cosa c'è di così difficile mi
direte nell'innovare in fondo prendo tre
ingredienti li combina insieme ho già
innovato no non è così facile
non è neanche una questione di chimica
la chimica e la scienza del governo i
sapori e profumi in parte anche i colori
aggiustare in sapori profumi non è
difficile se non è gioia e aggiungete
zucchero oppure un dolcificante se non è
abbastanza acido mettete l'aceto il sale
poi non ne parliamo
punto chiave la vera difficoltà della
creazione in cucina sono le strutture le
consistenze
provate a savona frolla a metterci
dentro l'olio al posto del burro ma
anche soltanto se ci mettete il
fruttosio che sembra uno zucchero più
salutare al posto del solito e zucchero
da cucina
la folla viene molliccia non saranno e
se che non sarà mai croccante una
meringa appiccica se ci mettete il
fruttosio c'è problema delle strutture
un problema pazzescamente difficile e
non a caso la grande rivoluzione nella
cucina moderna contemporanea anzi
comincia proprio dall affrontare il
problema delle nuove strutture con la
rivoluzione comincia con questo piatto
storico 1994 ferran adrià ha destinato a
diventare il più grande cuoco della sua
epoca si inventa questa minestra di
verdura testurizzata ha destrutturato il
minestrone qual è l'idea minestrone
buono ci sono delle buone verdure ma non
è elegante come consistenza non lo poco
queste mai nuovo ristorante a tre stelle
di alta cucina
se invece cambio le consistenze avendo
tutto più piacevole potrà pensare a
patate farinose fagioli fibrosi il
basilico sfratto lui ha messo una
gelatina di basilico
ma soprattutto ha inserito una grande
novità quella spuma violetta che vedete
sulla destra una spuma di barbabietola
che ha ottenuto con il sifone che lo
strumento che sta al centro il sifone
l'avevano inventato gli austriaci per
montare la panna più rapidamente lui
realizza il primo hackeraggio della
cucina moderna cioè usa il sifone per
fare qualcosa di completamente diverso
rispetto alla sua funzione originaria
riesce a ottenere questa schiuma che sa
solo di barbabietola perché prima si
facevano le mura si aggiungevano le uova
e la panna quindi le mosse sapevano di
barbabietola ma anche di uova e di panna
lui tiene un sapone lo saprò in purezza
va avanti esplorando ma si rende conto
che il cuoco brancola senza la scienza
che lo aiuta quindi nel 1997 pubblica un
libro che è una pietra miliare nella
storia della cucina si intitola i
segreti del bulli dove scrive questa
affermazione profetica se riusciamo ad
avviare una collaborazione fra pochi
scienziati i confini si aprono e le
possibilità per la nuova arte culinaria
sono illimitate e il 97 timidamente nei
primi anni 2000 cominciamo le prime
collaborazioni in realtà lo sviluppo
della scienza era arrivato proprio al
momento giusto perché in quegli anni era
nata una nuova disciplina che gli
inglesi chiamano soft matter i francesi
matière mall tutta europa la chiama
materia molle noi in italia chiamiamo
materia soffice perché ci sono un po
schifo parlare di mazzarri a molle che
il mio corso all'università si chiama
fisica della materia soffice ma di fatto
in materia molle giusto due persone per
dirvi che cos'è la scuola vi insegnano
anche la materia tre stati solido
liquido e gassoso il solido e rigido
indeformabile una forma un volume propri
il liquido ha un volume ha segnato ma
occupa la forma del recipiente
il gas invece si espande liberamente
bene con questa classificazione in
cucina non ci fate niente trattate sale
lo zucchero poi finisce lì perché una
marmellata non è né solida nei liquidi
dalla polenta non ne parliamo la panna
montata
guardate non è solo questione di cucina
la materia della nostra quotidianità non
rientra in queste classificazioni
gabbati vestiti che avete addosso sonoro
mature sono scafandri sono già che
devono prendere alla forma del corpo
quindi non sono solidi
non sono neanche liquidi sono materia
soffice ecco questa è la materia soffice
la materia soffice diventa lo strumento
di battaglia lo strumento creativo di
questa nuova cucina e arriviamo a adrian
sulla prima sulla copertina del new york
time magazine nel 2003 con una sua
creazione basata su questi studi è
un'area vedete un'area cosa è un'area è
una schiuma molto rarefatta come quella
della birra come quella del cappuccino
che ha una funzione gastronomica molto
interessante perché ci porta in bocca
degli aironi anche dei sapori senza
riempie una di materia perché il gas
svapora con un'area di cui posso far
mangiare il tabacco sopra un gelato con
un'area voi a casa prendete e succo di
limone un po di lecitina di soia montate
con il minipimer la mettete su un pesce
su una sogliola invece di uccidermi la
sogliola con le gocce di limone che vi
corrodono la bocca
date un leggero sentore di limone al
vostro pesce e non date né meno calorie
meglio di così andiamo avanti
adria è veramente un genio il caviale di
melone questo è un primo esempio delle
innovazioni portate da questa grande
rivoluzione usando una sostanza nuova
già usata dall'industria alimentare che
si chiama alginato di sodio prepara
queste palline che sono mobili gommose
all'esterno era piede di un gustosissimo
succo di limone concentrato all'interno
caviale di melone con un altro
ingrediente che si chiama gomma santana
andoni luis aduriz altro grande poco
spagnolo realizza questo dolce che si
chiama vanità la vanità sono queste
bolle 18
svaniscono quando le mangiate ma il tema
delle spugne e costante nella cucina di
a2 sulla data questa bellissima spugna
che ha creato invitando una forma
naturale ci sono nuovi ingredienti
adesso al supermercato comprate l'agar
agar vent'anni fa non sapete nemmeno
cose non sapevate nemmeno cosa fosse
poi ci sono nuovi strumenti questo e
l'azoto liquido facciamo un gelato in
dieci secondi stappando una bottiglia di
moscato in mantecando la all'istante
vi preannuncio che nella pausa pranzo
potrete assaggiare una creazione
preparata con l'azoto liquido che sono
hip hop con di panna montata al caffè
alla vaniglia
proseguiamo piatto iconico della cucina
contemporanea sulla destra
mare montagna mare monti di joan roca
un'ostrica cruda servita su un
distillato di terra di bosco come fa a
distillare alla terra di bosco con
questo strano marchingegno che vedete
alla sinistra si chiama volta va la
prova è un distillatore a bassa
pressione che fa bollire l'acqua a 40
gradi
a quel punto distillate senza cuocere
quindi mantenete gli aromi crudi di
tutto quello che avete perfino del
muschio su questa tecnologia si basa
anche questo il gas trovò a che una
pentola depressione
togliamo l'aria perché togliamo l'area
perché così l'acqua buona temperature
basse ci facciamo le fritture a bassa
temperatura che sono croccantissima ma
non voce hanno mai non si scuriscono non
sono nemmeno dannose come le fritture
normali non soltanto i nuovi strumenti
hanno caratterizzato la nuova cucina
guardata e questa è una creazione del
nostro carlo cracco sono gli spaghetti
di solo ruolo che ha ottenuto con la sua
tecnica del nuovo marinato che è tipica
della cucina molecolare italiana è una
cucina che sfrutta ingredienti
tradizionali utensili assolutamente
tradizionali ma usati in modo nuovo e
creativo carlo ha preso un tuorlo d'uovo
l'ha messo su un letto di zucchero e
sale la ricoperto
sale dopo qualche ora il tuolo si
rapprende si asciuga diventa lavorabile
ci fate gli spaghetti di solo tuo volo
con tecniche simili anni fa ci siamo
inventati la frittura nel glucosio
leggiamo nello zucchero fuso così non
ungiamo e abbiamo tutta una serie di
altri vantaggi un altro piatto che vi
lascio come esercizio quando tornate a
casa
si chiamerà cagliata d'uovo prendete una
padella ci rompete dentro 234 uovo
quelle che volete
poi invece di cuore alain versate dentro
alcol etilico per liquori
mescolate si rapprende all'istante come
quando si fa il formaggio sembra quasi
costo l'album e diventa bianco questo
punto lo strizzate perché altrimenti di
ubriacate togliete la cole in eccesso
lo potete anche lavare con un po d'acqua
fredda anzi meglio lavarlo strizzate
tutto e avete una ventina la cagliata
d'uovo potete mangiare in mille modi
l'ultimo esperimento che ha fatto e
condita con un po di me di miele vi
garantisco che è fantastica ma
sbizzarriti di una materia prima neutra
potete fare quello che volete bene tutte
le cose che vi ho raccontato
adesso finalmente hanno preso forma come
vedete la gastronomia è una scienza
allora noi tutti che abbiamo lavorato su
tutto questo negli ultimi anni un certo
punto ci siamo detti
e bene che questi lavori non vadano
persi e bene dire che bisognerebbe
creare una nuova disciplina che si
chiama gastronomia scientifica ci siamo
riuniti a marzo a barcellona
all'università in una veste estremamente
ufficiale e ne è uscito questo manifesto
di barcellona che va sta girando per il
mondo dove si sostiene esattamente
quello che vi ho raccontato in questo
quarto d'ora cioè che l'uomo ha bisogno
di mangiare bene per il suo benessere
psicofisico che la cucina è un attività
caratterizzanti dell'umanità in quanto
tale culturalmente che la gastronomia
deve essere una disciplina olistica non
si può avere nuovo tutto fisica chimica
biologia ci sono aspetti psicologici
emozionali filosofici culturali questo è
il manifesto di barcellona ma la cosa
più bella è che questo manifesto di
barcellona real in
alla perfezione una sorta di sogno di
profezia che ci ha lasciato scritto il
primo gastronomo dell'età moderna un
signore che si chiamava briglia savarin
primi dell'ottocento che scrive un
trattato intitolato la fisiologia del
gusto
all'inizio di questo trattato con una
serie di aforismi e ce n'è uno in
particolare che era veramente profetico
ed è questo dice la scoperta di un
piatto nuovo giova più alla felicità
dell'uomo che non la scoperta di una
nuova stella
grazie
[Applauso]